.
L'assaut du Capitole a été
la "culmination d'une tentative
de coup d'État".le
de la commission d'enquêtedu Coe
du 6 janvier 2021, qui a
la responsabilité exacte
de Donald Trump
dans cette insurre
Selon eux, il serait carrément
au centre de la conspiration
qui visa
au pouvoir.
Un an et demi après
cette journée qui a marquére, 1s
et 140 000 documents plus tard.
C'est donc le début
des audiences publiques
Une véritable tempête médiatique
à Washington.
Azeb, dès l'ouverture,
on a appris qu'une partie
de l'entourage imm croyait pas
que l'élection avait été volée.
Exactement, parce
des mani. Donald Trump
était normalement président, on
lui avait volé ces élections. Et
on apprend que son ministre de
la Justice avait beau cherchait
toutes saçons de dire
que c'était des fraudes, il al t
pas que c'était des fraudes, que
cette machine avaichine avaichie
et que dans la trompe avaient
utilisé des machines...
William Barr a dit qu'il
Et d'emblée, la représentante
républicaine qui fait parti du
comité a affirmé que Donald
Trump a incité la foule àer comà
allumer la mèche.ÉcoutÉcoutÉcoÉn
ministre de la justice, suivied.
témoignage on a entendu une
policière qui a été gravement
blessée lors de ce
-
Et c'est probablement le
témoignage le plus
Elle explique deput
lorsqu'il était face-à-face
manifestants, ils ont traité de
traîtr.
Elle a ts
manifestssayait dessayait dessas
empêchst tombée.st tombée.st toé
entraînée pour arrêter des
suspects, pour contrôler des
manifestations, mais n'a jamais
été entraîné pour une zone de
si vous voulez. Elle a carnage,e
chaos sur le capital et que
lle n'avait imaginé que
se produirait aux États-Unis.
c'était la petite fille d d'unen
propre pays en guerre. Écoutez
- Donc, Céline, ces audiences
vont se poursuivre.
Est-ce qu'on essaie de
démontrer, c'est vraiment le
lien entre Donald Trump et cet
assaut du Capitole
c'est que c'était une stratégie.
Est-ce qu'on a vu
filmés par un documentariste.
On voit vraiment qu'il avait une
préparation de cet assaut du
Capitole, on voula
le vote, le résultat électoral
et empêcher la certificatio